but we're not talking about going to the
entirety of a single agency and
literally just firing every single
person and then leaving an empty room
he's saying there are people who need to
be fired who can't be fired but like
imagine if you bought a pizza restaurant
and everybody in there was sitting
around and nobody was working and you're
like why am I paying you people like
Union contract you can't fire us and so
then some guy's like okay well I'm gonna
buy this pizza place and then I'm
sending a new policy I'm gonna negotiate
a new contract and say I can fire if you
don't do your job so then the people who
work there all team up conspire accuse
you of crimes and have you arrested
Ian have you ever lived through a
government shutdown yes because you have
because you're yeah
no no no like a government shutdown at
the end of the year when when they don't
meet the Appropriations bills right and
they only have essential people working
right from the federal government you
don't notice it you don't feel it at all
a day in your life they could cut all of
those people if you are non-essential if
you're a non-essential worker and you
get laid off during a government
shutdown I'm sorry goodbye